[Music]  do you ever feel like your life has  turned into something you never intended  [Music]  I'm worried about you are you sleeping  you scared me the last time we talked  you know me I never sleep my ex-husband  used to call me a nocturnal animal I  didn't know you had an ex-husband I've  been thinking about him a lot lately and  then recently he sent me this book face  written it's violent and then sad and he  dedicated it to me  did you love him I did something  horrible to him  are we gonna do it's a question of how  serious you are about seeing justice  done talk to this you'll regret it I  really wanted to be this person that you  thought I was  you're crazy hang on baby say you'll  never find out when you love someone you  have to be careful I did it you might  never get it again  it's fun to kill people we should try it  sometime nobody is away with what you  did buddy love time death now these  three things connect every single human  being on earth we long for love